hey what up it's your boy bino rado
checking me out on the bootleg kid
podcast
who like cav show special guest my guy
man vino rideau is in here
welcome welcome good to be back of
course um sorry for the wait too yeah
uh what is the what are we waiting for
uh it's been two years bro since i've
since outside yeah that's been two years
you know what i guess it has been two
years yeah man because that was like
very early pandemic yeah
you know it's crazy
yeah that's crazy because like it just
this whole thing has flown by so fast
like to think it was two years ago that
we were
barely getting started with this
[ __ ] like it's crazy to think kobe
was even around that long
right man two years ago and i just feel
like the first sorry for the weight that
was like a
you know i'm saying it really shook the
ground up you know what i'm saying for
me
in the city when i dropped that project
it's a lot of classics you know what i'm
saying and i toured that project so i
know
how important it is you know what i'm
saying to the city so i just it's only
right i come back with a part two yeah
and you had like six tape two in between
so you know you kind of give gave people
a nice little
incredible body of work with blast yeah
there's still some vibes out there man
you know i'm saying i'm still
present and everything but as far as
just giving you like the full beno
experience
it's been a minute uh you have draco on
the album and me and draco uh talked to
extent about you guys potentially doing
a whole album together when he was alive
um
he played me some stuff uh
obviously talk about your relationship
with him um i know
people have polarizing relationships
with draco he either really [ __ ] with
you or it was just kind of you were
either in or you were out
um he was a real nice guy to me but um
yeah he really [ __ ] with you so what
you know talk about y'all's relationship
and um and just you know obviously
losing him was a big loss for the city
in general yeah i mean you know me me
and draco you know we kind of from the
same area so it's like
we linked up early you know just it was
it was a mutual respect and you know i
had a lot of i got a lot of love for bro
just you know what i'm saying off of
everything we did from way back you know
i'm saying he was kind of you know i'm
saying he'd already had mr get though he
was already you know i'm saying draco
the ruler when he came and started
[ __ ] with me so you know i'm saying i
always appreciate that and
recognize it for what it is so our
relationship was beyond the music like
half the time we kicked it we weren't
even thinking about no music [ __ ] you
know what i'm saying but a lot of times
it was in the studio and we ended up
making crazy [ __ ] if i told him just
pull up
he for sure
throw a verse on some [ __ ] like it's
nothing you know what i'm saying so we
ended up with so many songs
but
it was just like a real
real love and respect outside of music
here
yeah um how did you
pick this song for the album because
obviously you guys have a ton of music
that i don't know if we'll ever hear you
know what i mean it was i feel like
one i know how much bro like that so you
know what i'm saying when we did the
song we did a couple songs that night at
cash money ap studio mm-hmm and uh you
know what i'm saying he i wasn't even
trying to put him on that song like that
wasn't one of the ones i played him like
bro hop on this yeah he was more so on
so man like i need to get on this yeah
so i'm like for sure bro you know what
i'm saying he's been diverse it was
crazy
so you know that's really the last it's
probably the last record we recorded
together so it was already like
the idea was already there you know what
i'm saying prior to the tragedy you feel
me so i just wanted to follow through
with it and get them you know i'm saying
unapologetically draco
yeah uh what what when you have like
music like that with someone like draco
is it like is there a plan to put that
[ __ ] out or do you just kind of like
tell his team like hey whatever y'all
want to do like i'm like you know what i
mean like because obviously
it's more it's more so like it was it
was planned prior to like i turned that
record in so long ago no i already know
yeah yeah i just mean in terms of like
you know you guys obviously he told me
that he had planned on trying to do a
whole project with you yeah that's nice
i'm pretty sure that's on camera too
yeah yeah
no for sure like i didn't i think i just
said that in the interview too it's it's
just we never really sat down and like
tried to track lists nothing or tried to
like right right it was very imp infant
in terms of just the process of doing
that it's just like man we got so much
music that's kind of how you know i'm
saying six tape started with me in black
it's like it was just like man we got
six songs just dropped six tight you
feel me
so yeah me and draco just had so much
music
so it's like man we got album word for
show
with six tape two i feel like there was
some real like hit records on there
but i do feel like when you have two
artists that have two labels
i always see those projects kind of fall
through the cracks in terms of getting
like the push to radio that they
probably deserve
because i do feel like there were some
records on there that could have went
crazy at radio but i feel like that
there wasn't like the heaviest like
button pressed on them is that due to
just two entities trying to you know
like what happened like in that oh no i
don't know
that's like that's something i can't
even put a finger on you know what i'm
saying i was just more so i feel like
this is like a great project bro and
there's like some [ __ ] on that project
it's like i mean [ __ ] like me just
gonna say they sleep you feel me or
whatever but
if i don't know
that's a tough question bro honestly
yeah
would you guys do another six tape i
said possibly
i mean it is uh i feel like every every
two or three years i should just throw a
little pack out you know what i mean
it's for the city maybe you know what
i'm saying for everybody get on the same
page and everybody got the time and
everything
uh this project obviously it's your
first one in two years
are you like
you just told me off camera because
we're talking about the only time i've
interviewed you solo was on zoom
or ig live or whatever the [ __ ] that
weird era of content
um but you were like yo my whole entire
def jam career has been on zoom loki
which is kind of like weird because you
sign this major deal it's a big look and
then the [ __ ] world shuts down
so things are obviously you have like
some cool activation [ __ ] going on
throughout the pandemic but like in
terms of like
this album
feels like the first one that you're
kind of like finally outside no pun
intended with um
what is the statement you're trying to
make with this and is are we look
considering this an album or is this a
mixtape or
it's it's it's a tape okay you know what
i'm saying it's a mixtape sorry for the
way it was the tape
so that's the tape um really it's just
i mean you know what
popular opinion is you know what i'm
saying aside from aside from very few la
music ain't what it used to be you know
what i'm saying or it's just they saying
we bunk over here bro you feel me so
who's saying this
twitter let's say the twitter sphere
let's say the twitter sphere i'm not
even gonna put
a region on it you know what i'm saying
but [ __ ] even l.a is saying [ __ ] you
know what i'm saying it's just
i'm not
i'm just trying to get back to playing
my role you know what i'm saying i feel
like when i dropped sorry for the weight
it was it was a vibe you know what i'm
saying it was a lot of dancing going on
it was a lot of energy it was in a dark
time period
and uh you know i hit him with like
records like missy and you know i'm
saying [ __ ] like that and it's like i
just want to get back to that give him
new records because like i said i'm
still i just toured two-year-old music
that shit's crazy that's all that so you
know
it's crazy you know what i'm saying so
it's like i just want to see you know
i'm saying if i put some new energy out
there it's me
i'm saying how it's gonna feel what do
you think uh cause i do feel like la
music in general is probably more
collaborative nowadays in terms of like
you'll see like a lot of the younger
artists going and supporting each other
some guys aren't really wrapped up in
the politics you know so that's possible
um
but
i do see the discussions where people
will say
uh
la music
doesn't really support it outside of la
or the west coast you know what i'm
saying and i feel like you kind of bring
um that variable to the table
where you're making music that
doesn't sound so
la if that makes sense like i could hear
your [ __ ] in atlanta or you know what i
mean i think that's why that's how roddy
broke out that's how blast broke out
it's just like do you feel like that
that is a problem in terms of just like
la in general just like
you know
it's it's it's something can be big here
it could be big in portland it could be
big in phoenix vegas whatever but like
it's like how do you get past
those
markets
i feel like
we we
i mean to be simple bro like we lost a
key piece you know what i'm saying of
our foundation of course nip you know
what i'm saying so it's like our
foundation isn't really solid right now
if you ask me you know what i'm saying
like i feel like roddy is holding [ __ ]
down for sure you know what i'm saying
and now and nipples are part of his
foundation exactly like anybody making
[ __ ] look good it's a lot of people out
here you know what i'm saying it's
making [ __ ] look good but we just need a
solid foundation
really leaders
yeah we missing that you know i'm saying
nothing ain't really nothing
you know
yeah no that's that's fair because if
you think about like nip's role like
to a guy like yourself or to a guy like
roddy like he very much was like uh
first of all had the ear and the eye for
talent but also
had like the
the principles to like kind of instill
and be like hey look you know you got to
move this way you got to do this way and
you know that's real for people who
don't know like what was your original
um
or like like how did you and nipsey
originally link up what were the origins
of y'all's relationship because
obviously you know
it's been a couple of years in fact so
how did you guys originally link up he's
the first guy um that i saw really like
standing next to in the industry yeah um
when you had bleached hair he effects
yeah uh i just always tell you know adam
like i see adam running marathon story
like bro like what's up you know what
i'm saying like me trying to tap in with
nick because adam's somebody that tapped
in early let's add them all money in for
anybody that don't know but
you know what i'm saying adam just even
knowing adam he know all the new music
gonna come out he'll tell you some [ __ ]
like you can tap in with this [ __ ] and
then [ __ ] blow up like two weeks later
like adam always been that type of [ __ ]
so he he he was tapped in with me early
he'll just tell me like you know when
the time right bro you know i'm saying
we're gonna put it together
i get to call up casey veggie's phone
and his nip
so nip like broke put up to the studio
so you know i'm saying shout outs casey
for making it because casey veggies i
just saw casey at south by southwest my
guy got jacked
he's like he's like you know
he ain't like casey veggies he's like
casey [ __ ] vegetables you know
what i'm saying like
that [ __ ] looks like he's on
keto or something yeah i call him
vegetables that's yeah
but uh yes i put straight up you know it
was a no-brainer never said pull up i
pulled up and uh that day we actually
did
uh the field we younged off
so you know what i'm saying like looking
back on that is crazy it's like damn
like a [ __ ] pulled up linked with nip
and dolphin the same day you feel me
that's like a
session that will be like
100 years from now you could talk like
people will watch this and be like damn
yeah like it [ __ ] my head up like it's
just like
wicked but
uh we make the field we made another
joint that day
and uh
yeah i just pulled up like after that
i'll just keep pulling up as long as
it's cool you know he if he hit me you
know what i'm saying i'm sliding even if
i'm just chilling i'm chilling you feel
me watching bro work being a part of his
process and we just developed a
relationship outside the music just
because i was willing you know what i'm
saying to put into work hungry yeah
like
i feel like he saw that in me and he
believed in me
so would there was there ever any plans
of you
officially getting signed
um you know i always hear rumors of that
from other people right but it never
actually kind of got brought to you you
know while he was here not today until
he passed like people tell me like [ __ ]
[ __ ] every time you
talk about that [ __ ]
but
he never mentioned it to me what is the
studio session with dolph and nipsey
like are they giving each other ideas
who's like yo i got this is who's doing
the hook like like who like like what is
the creative vibe because everyone who's
a writer who's a rapper some people
don't write [ __ ] down some people going
to do punch in line by line like what is
that whole because that is a moment in
history that you were with dolph and nip
at the same time create music like what
is that like bro who who's taking the
lead in the session so nick so he i
didn't even know like what was happening
at first i just pulled up we chopped it
up for a second
he just went hopped in the booth you
feel me i hear him start laying his
vocals you know bar for bar so i'm like
okay like that's hard like i'm thinking
it's just i'm gonna watch bro do his
thing or something mm-hmm you come out
like you got something for this i'm like
hell yeah so i'll go in and i lay a hook
so they're like oh okay but the whole
time you know what i'm saying i was i'm
lying alive i was pulling up bro so you
know what i'm saying i'm getting faded
you know what i'm saying by that time uh
we like two records in we did two
records young dog pulled up later okay
okay so but like later that night so i
just remember waking up like so he was
he was in a lean coma and you woke up
and dolph was there
like
hey you know this dump right here and
i'm like oh it's still like you know
like okay crazy like you feel me so the
dog just vibing to the record he'd go in
and start laying his focus bar for bar
and it was just you know what i'm saying
that was that it was it was it was crazy
because you know nip he got the studio
all blue his blue lights everywhere at
all times
so you know what i'm saying it was just
like the vibe the energy was crazy
is nip the kind of guy who would
lay his vocals down line by line or
would he like
without writing [ __ ] down i feel like it
depends how you felt
you know what i'm saying some [ __ ]
he was you know he was always
intentional or some [ __ ] i see him
writing some [ __ ] down and you know
really kind of taking his time or a
different approach to it at least what
about you like obviously you have a lot
of melodies so will you go in and like
put the melody down first fill in the
lyrics later like what's your process um
i kind of just jump in the booth uh
just play around with the melody a
little bit and uh just start filling in
the words honestly bro
a pattern i [ __ ] with
and then i just go with it just start
popping my [ __ ] for did you have a very
uh
like to me a unique sound in in in just
music in terms of your pitch your tone
like what are your like can you point to
any influences that you kind of take
from in terms of like [ __ ] you were
growing up listening to or oh
man
i really [ __ ] with uh
i guess as far as my sound goes you know
i really [ __ ] with with with future you
know i'm saying i think pluto is crazy
um i think the you know what i'm saying
islam got a lot of influence on me you
know i'm saying i
approach making a record
uh i used to lock in with johnny cinco a
lot you know what i'm saying he really
was like you know coach like he kind of
you know what i'm saying
gave me you know a lot of the game as
far as
you know i'm saying the recording
process and how to keep up you know what
i'm saying and stay here so
shout out shout out to john poppy for
show
you know
yeah i mean i listen to everything bro
if you see her and talk to her i look
like i listen afro beat you know what
i'm saying i listen to old school i turn
some fuji
some some
some uh
lucy pearls you know what i'm saying
like oh yeah like i really listen to
everything but
yeah i really [ __ ] with with slime
were you ever able to get in with a guy
like thug or yeah i mean thug we got a
few records but we got
went out
his specific
situation is kind of like shining a
light on people
um
having possibly having like lyric shoes
against them
which hopefully gets shot down because i
think it's stupid as [ __ ] i think in new
york they just passed a law where you
can't do that anymore but obviously
what's going on with him is in georgia
but um
when you see that kind of [ __ ] happening
does it make you any sort of more
hesitant to
you know
spit some entertaining fiction on
records because it might be in
interpreted the wrong way
oh i could see how i make you know i'm
saying people uncomfortable but
you feel me i ain't
i'm cool you know what i'm saying i'm
out the way bro you know what i'm saying
you know what i think needs to start
happening and i think this is like if
this really becomes a thing i'm not sure
it's going to become a thing but if like
they really start pressing the line on
rap lyrics at the beginning of
everyone's albums there needs to be
a [ __ ] disclaimer
imagine if when you press play on an
album the first the intro is just
this is uh these are tales of fiction no
different than a movie when you press
play none of this is factual i mean it's
really the same [ __ ] bro you know what
i'm saying ain't nothing to go start
locking up lorraine's tape because he
was old exactly it's the same it's
literally the same [ __ ] and you and i
know most of these guys
most of them are just
it's it's not real
which is okay because if the music is
good who gives a [ __ ] i don't expect the
rock to be
[ __ ] hobbs and shaw jumping out of
cars and [ __ ] like i'm watching the
movie it's great the [ __ ] music is
great i don't give a [ __ ] like most you
know obviously
i'm old enough and been in this [ __ ]
long enough to know that
like most people are just normal dudes
you know what i mean who probably had
like who was around some [ __ ] or maybe
if they were involved in some [ __ ] it
was very minimal you know what i mean
but
yeah it is very much like yo how can you
prosecute somebody based on
entertainment like these are song lyrics
like like what like
it's thirsty bro um like when wesley
snipes got hit for tax evasion they
didn't use like some of his like they
didn't say you also murdered a bunch of
people in blade and you killed the 12
vampires
that [ __ ] is burnt bro
yeah
it's crazy man it it it's unfortunate um
you obviously you do have
roddy's on the on the album you guys put
the single out um
what is uh you know i just had roddy on
the show last week and he seems to be
like
out of his funk
um you know i know he told head that uh
his energy wasn't right on on the last
project but like
what's what's your relationship like
with roddy obviously both of you guys
are very much
you know products of nipsey in terms of
just like him putting his arm around
y'all officially you know what i mean so
what like like what what what's your
relationship with someone like roddy man
i'm just you know proud to see how far
bro come you know what i'm saying like
that's somebody i could hit and i know
i'ma get some genuine back mm-hmm you
know what i'm saying just from the
regular like you know
it's he
carrying this [ __ ] bro you know what i'm
saying
i feel like you know what i'm saying
with that album it was a lot of a lot of
criticism you know i'm saying i was
tuned in but
it's big three [ __ ] like going stupid
and that real talk [ __ ] is hard this big
three [ __ ] going stupid so i'm just i'm
happy for bro you feel me i'm proud to
see him doing his thing
and he know that he feel me
hey we got to stop the interview real
quick to tell you about our family our
good folks at odd socks you see me look
these are odd socks basics on my skinny
white [ __ ] legs
i love odd socks go to
oddssocksofficial.com
you're going to get 20 off at checkout
if you use the promo code bootleg kev
that's one word bootleg kev now they got
odd socks which are great my favorites
are the basics they also you know you
got the license one these are the
twizzlers these are baywatch socks but
then you got the basics now these are
what these are just the plain boys man
they're so comfy all right i always got
the white basics the black basics on and
i always got odd socks underwear on too
they got the draws all right so what are
you doing go to oddssocksofficial.com
use the promo code
bootleg cav save 20 off check out these
[ __ ] draws kool-aid
underwear ladies and gentlemen what are
we doing
odd socks official.com bootleg kev is
the promo code save 20 off right now
let's get back to the interview yeah do
you feel like you ever get into the
situation because i'm assuming you
record a lot
do you have tons of music you probably
got just just
do you ever feel like
you get to a point where it's it gets
hard to like
pick records for your album and do you
also
maybe have a song that maybe you
recorded a year and a half ago
that you've been listening to for a year
and a half straight that at the time
you're like this is a [ __ ] hit but
now that we gotta pick for the album
it's old to you so that [ __ ] gets left
off like is that like a battle you have
is like someone who records it like at a
high output hell yeah bro like it's like
i'll be tired of the whole i literally
gotta not listen to it like a few months
before that because once you do the new
[ __ ] you're like man that's just old
like this new shit's better that [ __ ]
already oh to me like this [ __ ]
dropped tonight this [ __ ] already oh to
me you know what i'm saying like it's
already like but
it like i get the new burst of energy
when i get to see the reactions and you
know what i'm saying get to perform the
songs and [ __ ] like that
but it's like yeah i'm already on a
whole new wave and a whole new sound
keep it honey like i'm already on the
album you know i'm trying to put the
album out by the end of the year
so
that's not a i mean that going going two
for two for the year yeah i'm trying to
bleed them and i ain't even all i'm
trying to do it's a little you know what
i'm saying look
[ __ ] here and there but i'm for sure
trying to
give him the album before the year for
sure so
what is the is there like a is the
approach different with the album um
definitely i feel like because i never
dropped the album right you've only done
tapes outside was a mixtape you made it
very clear yeah like i'm i'm trying to
i like i look back at everybody debut
album and it's just you know i'm saying
crazy you feel me like reasonable doubt
doggy style get rich or die trying
please excuse me for being anti-social
we can go i mean my crazy life we can go
on and on i just want to make sure i
want to be certain and
you know what i'm saying in a good head
space to where i can completely focus on
building a great body of work you want
it to be a classic yeah and i feel like
i'm i'm in that moment now where i can
take that approach
yeah i always tell everybody that first
album is it's gotta be
you gotta the bars is up here that's why
i thought it was so hard that like if
you really think about it victory lap is
nipsey's only album
now he had mixtapes bodies at work but
victory lap was so intentional so well
thought out so planned so perfectly
executed because he knew
that that legacy of your first album has
got to be
it's got to be up on the wall with good
kid mad city and 50 and all that [ __ ]
kendrick did the same [ __ ] bro you know
what i'm saying so it's like i pay
attention to [ __ ] like that and i try to
you know what i'm saying
just come as correct as i can for what
were your thoughts did you enjoy the
kendrick album
yeah you know what i'm saying
i feel like
i i appreciate it bro you know what i'm
saying it's like it's like an art piece
for me you know what i'm saying
i feel like
[ __ ] just looking to just
slide around and turn up all the time
you feel me and you got that in there
too you got that the rich spirit [ __ ] is
crazy attractive that's my [ __ ] that
[ __ ] is crazy
but i feel like the rest of the music is
a lot of
enlightenment you know what i'm saying
it's like
it's it's it's a vibe it's kind of like
it's like a learning experience it's
like music to like live to yeah like you
know what i mean if i'm if i'm getting
on a flight i'll run that through you
know what i'm saying you know what i'm
saying like but i feel like getting in
the car with the homies you feel me they
trying to you know you know drill time
so they they they're trying to put on uh
[ __ ] futures new album you know yeah
but it's like yeah i i slept
that [ __ ] at the house you know what i'm
saying just chilling just you know what
i'm saying really trying to soak up what
are you talking about so i can kind of
you know just trying to pick his brain
really
but y'all [ __ ] without him
um we talked about earlier you and drago
talking about doing a joint project you
and blast have a joint project if
there's another artist out there
that you could do a joint project with
or maybe you might be working on one
with i don't know who would that be
salon
doug
that would be crazy it should be od
i hope he gets out man that's who bro
yeah it's rough it is rough
you know
not to get dive too much into this thing
but the the best part about the the the
silver lining is that it was uh
the georgia state police rico it wasn't
a federal rico at least not yet
so it's it wasn't like it was the
[ __ ] fbi it was the georgia exactly
it was a georgia rico so you know and i
can only assume that georgia don't have
their [ __ ] together all the time because
it is a [ __ ] incompetent state so and
i just i just know that's a good dude
you know what i'm saying i mean we
talking about it
[ __ ] hit me i mean every other day i
love you bro you're good you feel me are
you feeling like just off gp like he
just
i just know slime for being like as
solid as they come very so i hate to see
him in that situation for sure yeah we
just had snap dog on the show and he
said that he was like hanging out with
doug for like a year straight and he was
like
he noticed doug noticed he always would
have these glasses on
and because his eye vision is [ __ ] up
and he said that doug just randomly hit
him and said hey you got an appointment
at the doctor tomorrow to go get your
eyes done and he paid for it
i guess shit's crazy like no who's doing
that you know what i mean and like
snapdog's not assigned to ysl like he's
just someone who was around you know
like
like not a lot of people are that
generous
or thoughtful especially in the music
industry
most of these fools is fake as [ __ ]
that's a [ __ ] they'll let you
hang out
because they're they're something that's
beneficial to them yeah when you're
hanging around
second that [ __ ] goes away
but it's funny i said that [ __ ] in the
interview i said one of the most solid
[ __ ] the most solid [ __ ] next to nick
that i met in this [ __ ] was long
wow i said that says a lot man a minute
ago because he's just a real [ __ ] bro
like he
saw 100 and it's like it's like it feel
like family he treats you like you
famous he [ __ ] with you [ __ ] with you
all the way
i swear to god what is uh your favorite
song on this album or mixtape we'll call
it
it's it's hard to choose i'm really off
uh if you ever
you got katelyn on there you got um
obviously roddy uh draco i mean you got
some some yeah my bro cardio you know
what i'm saying that's i feel like
i don't know i hate i hate saying like
next up and [ __ ] like that he's next
step
he
finished shake some [ __ ] up for sure is
he
like your artist
i'm an artist he independent you know
what i'm saying making lane for himself
from out here yeah dope yeah check him
out he's doing this [ __ ] for sure
yeah so i saw his name i was like i
don't know who that is i gotta check him
out i mean he's on the [ __ ] project
we got a few joints we got a we got a
joint called what it is and we got one
uh
on this recent project it's
crazy we performed it on the last tour i
guess
caitlin's dope too man he's a good guy
okay the next twin he also
people don't like caitlyn's one of the
smartest dudes that i like sat down with
i'm like this
people don't realize this guy's like a
college athlete who like went to [ __ ]
sd you know like he's a he's a very he's
got his head on straight he's very um
[Music]
he's also very intentional yeah he's
like very cerebral dude you can't even
[ __ ] your head up you know i'm saying
he'll say some [ __ ] too you [ __ ] hate
it he's a beast too
super beast yeah yeah i love caitlyn you
guys should do a [ __ ] project
together okay yeah that should be crazy
that'd be crazy yeah i ain't gonna lie
we damn near did like in the night we
made like [ __ ] six or seven songs in
the night
and i think all that [ __ ] leaked i think
like damn notice where does it leak
anymore youtube
because back in the day it used to leak
like i go download it off limewire or
[ __ ] like what what the torrent sites
or like a message board and now like
when someone's like it leaked i'm like
yeah but like where do i [ __ ] youtube
bro yeah let me search your name
hello [ __ ] you know what's crazy is like
back in the day
there was like an era where
you could always get the albums a week
before no matter what because of cds
because the cd you had to go like think
about it
everyone
would turn in their album because the
cds had to get printed you know weeks
before
so it was always somebody in the middle
of that like
supply chain who would leak the album
so no matter what no matter who the [ __ ]
you were
you could go get the [ __ ] album early
and then a guy like me being 16 17 years
old would burn like a hundred copies and
take him to the sweater
and that's how my name is bootleg kev
hey you swear to god that was my hustle
man mixtapes bro i tell game this all
the time i'm like bro i had a [ __ ]
newborn baby and i sold i don't know
a thousand copies of the documentary
like a month before they dropped yeah
i'm like thank you for uh helping feed
my kids so you would sell them to the
swap meeting like no i'd pull up to the
swap meet and i would have like
i'd have a table with all the mixtapes
all the unit radios the southern smokes
whatever new albums that i would have
you really use the bootleg man for sure
that's hard i was getting to the check
every time i see drama i think i'm like
bro the gangster girl [ __ ] did well for
me bro
that's hard as [ __ ] yeah no i like
17 to like 19. that's like how i
supported my kid
i was working at the radio station for
free these [ __ ] weren't paying
me
on the weekends i was just going and
pirating everyone's [ __ ] and movies too
obviously movies had to pirate those but
it's like how like it's so crazy how
vital like well for me at least thinking
back on like my life like how vital the
bootleg man is to the culture bro i used
to pull up i'd have the card i'd be like
what y'all need i got the new matrix i
mean there's a [ __ ] standing up
in the middle of it but [ __ ] be like
what the new magic that [ __ ] don't come
off oh god like damn the bootleg man but
you would watch the movie you'd be like
you you get it
like yo what's the quality i'd like it's
good enough nah
i had it i remember you remember the
movie ross yeah yeah yeah i had a
bootleg man he used to be at the fish
spot this [ __ ] he like yeah i got rides
too i mean young [ __ ] right already
came out past
krumping was still like the [ __ ] he like
i rise to me and my cousin like what
and we grab that [ __ ] it's literally
this [ __ ] going around alleyways and
[ __ ] like just filming [ __ ] i remember
this one little [ __ ] like i'm a little
trouble
just got off but i know the bootleg man
voice because the [ __ ] laughing all the
movies so he made it yeah like he made
like he went around filming little knees
it was like a game changer because i was
bootlegging [ __ ] in like 0.30405.06
and then when like
the screeners would leak
it'd be the game changer because really
you were just hoping that someone went
in there with a real high quality
[ __ ] camcorder
and had a good seat right in the middle
you would deal with your cubbies you
would deal with people laughing you know
because you'd be like yo if it's a
comedy you know you're gonna hear the
crowd laughing
oh god nice welcome boy and then when
the screener started leaking it was like
oh
yeah and then i started selling the fake
uh nfl jerseys before those went rampant
because now you go to anybody go backs
and [ __ ]
just anything current jerseys i used
them for twenty dollars and something
like 150. yeah yeah but then like custom
started to be on my head i had like a
bunch of packages intercepted from
customs i don't know so like oh but now
you go to nfl game everyone's got fake
jerseys
all those [ __ ] jerseys on ebay y'all
are buying for 35 they're not real yeah
but
i want the old schools i'm trying to get
the old school dudes remember when the
laker jerseys were shiny yeah yeah just
to sparkle a little bit mm-hmm i don't
even wanna know are you a football fan
yeah would you are you a rams fan
uh shout out to rams you know what i got
a lot of love for the rams they [ __ ] the
rams
but it's cr i've been a chiefs fan all
my life god bless you thanks for having
original thoughts around here in los
angeles and not switching up like yg did
i mean hey man yeah i've been a chiefs
fan bro since like priests homes damn
priest holmes is a beast great fantasy
football court uh running back
so who was the quarterback back then
they had um
trent green because he was the guy who's
on the ramps and then kurt warner came
through and [ __ ] got him up out of
there yeah yeah trent greene yup oh god
shout out to the chiefs that's what made
you a chiefs fan [ __ ] my step pops was
the chiefs fan so you know all the time
every sunday i was watching the chief
so if the chiefs play the rams in the
super bowl you're [ __ ] with them
chiefs right yeah i'll be up there in
the chief's jersey all right i just want
to make sure you make sure because you
know what's going to happen on the ram
sideline the rams are going to try to
get you up there and hang out in the dj
boots with the homie and then they're
gonna give you a jersey with your name
on it and you gotta have the [ __ ]
i got it already i got the jersey i've
been to the stadium before it opened
though because i saw jason cash up there
and he had a rams jersey on and i was
like
ain't you a raiders fan
i said but you know it's funny the
clippers wanted me to come to have time
to do that no i said i couldn't do it
i couldn't bro and then shout out to the
clippers no disrespect i couldn't do it
i could i couldn't just bring myself to
you're a laker fan
the clipper hate in la i didn't realize
how
serious it was until i moved here
in the beginning of 2017
and i've my whole life i've been a i'm a
sons fan so i hate the lakers
now i've i have to my favorite player of
all time is lebron
so when lebron came to the lakers i had
a real
a real the suns were trash
i've been rooting for the cavs and the
heat wherever he's at i've been rooting
for so when he came to the lakers
i set aside
my hate and i said i'm rooting for
lebron because all the players that i
didn't like on the lakers aren't there
no more you know what i'm saying i'm not
mad at that but
i always said when i moved to la i was
like i told i told uh i told doc winter
i was like y'all i'ma just be a clippers
fan on that on the air even though i'm a
sons fan but you know i'm on the radio
in l.a so they want me to you know wear
dodgers hats and [ __ ]
like yo i'll just i'll just be the i'll
be the clipper guy on the radio but then
i came out here and i was like man [ __ ]
the clippers
yo i feel like i feel it like bro [ __ ]
them and then kawhi did my guy lebron
dirty as [ __ ] bro had the lakers hanging
out to the end of free agency thinking
he was going to join the [ __ ] lakers
and then sign with the clippers like a
[ __ ]
remember when that happened
and then they had to [ __ ] sign all
these guys off the scrap heap
they got rondo i mean they got a ring
though so that's all that matters but
kawhi did [ __ ] lebron dirty [ __ ]
hawaii man i'm hoping we get kyrie and
[ __ ] pg's from [ __ ] palmdale or
wherever the [ __ ] that's not even l.a
i didn't know that
good was kyrie man
kyrie to the lakers well there is some
breaking news
kevin durant just requested a trade
from the nets
so if you're the nets you kind of
you probably should try to get something
from kyrie blow the whole thing up
because i don't know if kyrie and ben
simmons is getting you much more than a
nine seat yeah
problem is is you got wes or russ who's
from the city i'm sure you got a
relationship with what russ yeah
yeah good guy i'm sure for sure for sure
just opted in he's making 47 million
dollars
let me ask you a question you're a laker
fan
russell westbrook is your friend
your actual friend
how do you feel what's going on
i feel like we're gonna get a chip this
year
you don't even believe that i do you're
a liar i'm dead ass bro i feel like i
feel like you know what i'm saying it's
trial and error man lots of error
i hate rush like uh did you say you hate
him or are you no no no
i just tapped in like uh like middle of
the season bro i'm like how you doing
like like you're good bro like just on
some regular [ __ ]
we talk about regular [ __ ] you like it
man
just trying to you know get this lakers
[ __ ] rolling you know what i'm saying
trying to you know work it out so i know
russ and he he beast you know what i'm
saying so yeah i know he gonna lock in
and figure it out i know he was facing a
lot of hate a lot of criticism you know
what i'm saying but
i know i know they're gonna figure it
out and bring bring it home this year do
you think you being his actual friend
you would be able to convince him to be
the sixth man
i could see
i wanna i want him i want him to wake up
that day
he's one of the highest usage rate
players of all time
so like he needs the ball in his hand so
it would make sense for him to come off
and just run that second unit for the
betterment of the lakers right i don't
know man we'll see if darvin hamm can be
the rust the rust whisperer
i want him kyrie and brian on the floor
at the same time i hate to see it man
cause i love lebron last year and listen
i hate the lakers you gotta understand
the suns have been good finally but i
just i'm like bro it's just
we we eliminated y'all the year before
you know what i mean which felt great
but uh that was sick um
but it was just like it just i'm like
bro lebron belongs in this [ __ ] in
the in the [ __ ] playoffs yeah it's
weird without him like i'm i'm not gonna
say he was born i'm not gonna say he's
it wasn't boring but it was just kind of
like even a celebration brother like
when going to stay one i kind of wanted
him to turn up like more you know what
i'm saying he didn't feel the same they
just feel like
i don't know bro i hate the warriors
it's my least favorite team of all time
whoa i just to me they're the
first of all
shout out to kd we won't even speak on
that era because he might be on the sun
soon so i don't need to use uh this
video is a reference point of a time in
which i was not fond of kd going to the
warriors and ruining the league for
three years
i mean i'm a lebron guy
so i'm [ __ ] watching these
[ __ ] go back and forth in the
finals
for four or five years straight and
i think that they have the most
bandwagon fans in the like it's it's
kind of like uh are you a wrestling fan
so you know how john cena is like the
team all the little [ __ ] kids like
but he's a cornball
the warriors are like the john cena the
nba it's like oh my [ __ ]
eight-year-old loves him because steph
curry it's i see i see what you're
saying it's like yeah of course you like
the [ __ ] it's easy to love the
warriors you know who i like though oh
jordan pool yeah jordan pool's nice i
like poo i just wanna i want them to
give give them some burn like i feel
like i hope they get them up out of
there i hope they can't afford to
re-sign them
bring them in the late show but then
[ __ ] don't care about the
luxury tax in the san francisco they're
so rich they're like yeah we'll pay 250
million dollars at the luxury tax we're
re-signing everybody
okay yeah i don't know the lakers hey
man we'll see
but you should talk to your boy russ
convince him to be the sixth man of the
year man
have that convo would you be sad if he
got traded
i would you'd be sad
as as a friend or as a fan
both
just because you feel me like it's
one it is cool having the homie here at
the house you feel me but it's cooler to
win
yeah but i feel like you can do that i
feel like you're more than capable i
hope you're right
we're gonna see man yeah frank vogel
ain't have it together last year wait
man i just can't wait to have jersey on
bring him out at the next show after he
went stupid and it's like you know what
i'm saying
because you know last time i brought him
out i remember seeing that creep walking
i saw yeah you had russell westbrook
[ __ ] walking on that stage in l.a but
everybody was just eating me up like you
know i'm saying all season like man
saying like man this show for sure for
sure for like all the type of [ __ ]
so i can't wait to we just we in the
chip you know what i'm saying we had to
pray turning up you know i'm saying and
i got through this jersey i appreciate
your level of commitment
to the to to to to uh
i don't know whatever we're calling this
because you goddamn no well you ain't
not going to the championship russell
westbrook is starting on the leg
i feel like we you [ __ ] are not
you need a d to go through some
hyperbaric chamber come out a whole new
man and he said he ain't put up a shot
at much that's what i'm saying this
[ __ ] is the glass
man it's crazy he liked the new uh uh
korean
he's like something every time he's like
feel like every time he's out there he
ends up on the floor grabbing his
[ __ ] leg and i'm like not again man
but you got you got a ring with 80 and
lebron that's all that matters
cause i always hear people talking like
damn like they gave up all those young
pieces that are out thriving in the nba
right now for a.d but i'm like you got a
ring out of it so that's why you did it
if if at the very least
there's no more rings with lebron it's
like you got one
you brought him here they bring y'all
back to the champ that it happened we
need some more fortunately it was in the
bubble you know we like like like laker
fans we ain't used to losing bro
i know y'all spoiled bro
having kobe in shaq for a [ __ ] decade
all we know is w so we know something
finished man do you watch uh hockey at
all like the la kings or anything i
don't watch it
like i'm not mad at it i [ __ ] with it
yeah it's a [ __ ] sport nobody
watches that [ __ ] i like the fighting
issue you go to the game it's fun though
yeah it looked like a good thing
you know i went to a la kings game and i
probably saw more porn stars at that
game than i seen in one place in my life
everywhere i turned around bro was the
la king's playoff game it was porn
[ __ ] everywhere like ones that i
recognized
which says a lot about me too obviously
if i'm recognizing that many that's
probably gonna be cuffing them busy what
about the uh have you been to an lafc
game
nah but i want to i actually i actually
[ __ ] with soccer bro those games are
crazy yeah i know what if the fan is
crazy the fans are [ __ ] crazy will
ferrell owns the team did you know yeah
well pharaoh he's a [ __ ] part owner of
the of the lafc shout out
[ __ ] anchorman ron burgundy man up
there in the stands losing his [ __ ]
that's crazy was he dale that's dale
right i'm still brothers
all right he's one of them yeah i think
that's dale right i don't know dale john
c reilly and uh that's a great movie
[ __ ]
that's hard
yeah
soccer soccer players be famous as a
[ __ ] the most famous
we're in like this small
we don't even understand the rest of the
world here
cause you look up these like ronaldo and
all these [ __ ] on ig they got
like 128 million followers while
lebron's got like 60. exactly that's
what
it's like this soccer [ __ ] is a whole
different ball game like i mean
obviously literally but
no the fame because it's worldwide bro
it's like reggaeton yeah type [ __ ] it's
like you don't even realize how big bad
bunny is
when people are like bad boy he's the
biggest artist in the world we'd be like
no it's drake
obviously like no it's [ __ ] bad bunny
i think he's out of here
that [ __ ] is crazy and it's like like
just under the whole culture behind it
like the uh
really know the breakdown between the
leagues but like uh like like um yeah
that's the only thing about soccer that
confuses me because there's there's like
all these there's like the euro league
there's just so many different there's
like the mexican teams that my homies
[ __ ] with so i don't understand like who
playing who it'd be like if there was
like 15 nfls yeah all over the world and
you'd be like
[ __ ] i got a few teams that i liked i
just don't know what league day and i
[ __ ] with uh manchester united
[ __ ] with chelsea city
i [ __ ] with uh
uh the brazil team
i i used to play brazil on uh fifa
because i always heard that i just i
would just pick brazil yeah i think they
got neymar and
messi
they got messy i think messi is are we
talking about the country of brazil i
don't know
i think messi's from argentina argentina
did i just say that country wrong is it
argentina i just said argentina
argentina it's a movie called green
street hooligans you ever seen that i've
heard of it i've seen like the poster i
i haven't watched it
it's about like the firms and [ __ ] like
outside like every i guess every team
got a fern so what a game going on like
the firms they link up at the local pub
seeing their songs and [ __ ] with their
beer and literally just link up with the
firm or the other team and have a big
ass brawl every game
well do you know like uh
did you see the video first of all
soccer fans are the most psychopathic
human beings in life that's crazy soccer
games in general not unless it's it's
here i'm not pulling up
i'm listen bro did you see the [ __ ] that
happened in mexico a few months ago they
had this fight where like [ __ ] 80
people died
see that's what i'm saying bro did y'all
see that
it was the most [ __ ] up [ __ ] bro the
video is like
i obviously looked all the video up
because i'm terrible but there's like
just if you were a part of the other
teams like like if you had the other
team shirt on they were literally
beating you to death stripping you naked
and dragging you it was [ __ ] crazy
bro take that [ __ ] seriously that's
pretty much what the movie was about you
gotta watch that [ __ ] it's a violent
[ __ ] it's some real gang [ __ ] that's
why they make such a big deal when these
big players change teams because it's
like imagine if someone [ __ ]
flip-flop gangs you know what i'm saying
they out there banging that [ __ ] like no
it's wild yeah they could keep all the
all those [ __ ] dusty ass irish and
english [ __ ] and
get [ __ ] faced at the pub and then go
beat the [ __ ] out of each other i'm okay
if i go to one of those games i'm gonna
be the [ __ ] vip box i don't want to
be amongst the [ __ ] the common folks
at one of them joints over there i'm
trying to come out with the team are you
going are you would you go out there and
obviously you know park hell yeah
i probably wouldn't get into squabbles
bootleg cab podcast got to stop things
real quick tell you about our good folks
at blue chew listen fellas if you're
trying to get your dick right you trying
to stay harder
everyone wants to be hard can you stay
hard
you know what i mean
if you need some help with your dick is
essentially what i'm trying to say
you need to go to bluetooth.com and get
down with uh something that i feel like
is imperative and having yourself a
lovely evening with a lovely young lady
or mail whatever you're into if you go
to bluetooth.com you will get a blue
chew it has the same active ingredient
as cialis and his viagra
right but guess what it doesn't have the
awkward doctor visits that's right you
don't got to wait in line at some lobby
to go get you some [ __ ] [ __ ] to get
your dick working and have some awkward
conversation with a nurse and then have
an awkward conversation with a doctor
and then he writes you a prescription
and then you go to the pharmacist and
then it's awkward because you pass them
the prescription and everyone knows
you're picking up dick stuff you know
what i'm saying no blue chew you go to
the website it's all online it gets sent
straight to your house in discrete
packaging in a chewable form
listen your first month free
right now when you go to bluechew.com
and you use the promo code bootleg
that's right you get the first month for
free
bluechew.com promo code
bootleg
thank me later all right go get your
dick together fellas have you been able
to
like go overseas at all like travel like
because of your music have you been able
to kind of like see the world yet i know
it's still early but
actually uh well you know i told you i
want to do my album for the end of the
year where i want to go do my home it's
a spot and it took me to uh it's in the
bahamas
but um
it's called albany and they got a studio
it's like a resort they got a studio
there called sanctuary oh sure and uh we
made a few joints you know what i'm
saying like uh
like just a few joints there and the
vibe was just crazy but i don't know i
actually want to go back there and do my
album but
just to go like perform or anything
overseas no i did
i ain't i mean i never been to london
you know what i'm saying only been like
a few places in mexico the spots you
know what i'm saying this is a little
bit watch you go for vacation
inclusive boys
oh my god yeah you already know but you
know i'm saying
you know what's crazy is uh
there's something about
west coast artists that japan loves
you gotta get booked in japan yeah uh
you know i think his name dj cools
yeah i tapped in with dj cools and he'd
be telling me like bro you got a lot of
fans out here just be like damn let's go
hang out in japan make a make a week out
of it dude
smoke just did that d smoke's been there
twice yeah i saw i saw uh something
about him in japan because i actually
got to go out there uh so my kids could
meet their family you know they have
japanese
oh you uh you have
half japanese children yeah well that's
dope yeah man
that's so is your baby mom is japanese
mm-hmm that's what's up yeah you gotta
now you see that you really gotta go
yeah i gotta go tap in you know what i'm
saying just
just see y'all it's just a lot of [ __ ] a
lot of [ __ ] i want to go to japan so bad
just because like all i eat is sushi and
i'm like i gotta have like
[ __ ] sushi sushi you know they got
crazy food out there bro like i i would
be sitting on youtube watching that [ __ ]
like you know what i'm saying like just
all the [ __ ] to do out there is like so
much [ __ ] bro
yeah and they got high level bootleg
[ __ ] out there
nah facts we talking about that [ __ ] oh
god there's streets out there
where it's like
they got fake apple stores dog
they like asia i don't know if japan
specifically but you could literally
walk into like [ __ ] will have a
whole apple store that's not real and
they're selling you fake a fake iphone
how the [ __ ] you got a fake iphone how
do you make that bro it's crazy because
i i just logged into my old whatsapp
like uh
from like 10 years ago but longer
and i had all these old messages from uh
all the chinese plugs i used to hit for
my [ __ ]
because i used to sell shoes too i sell
the jerseys all that [ __ ]
and
i had all these unchecked messages they
probably just send out mass [ __ ] these
[ __ ] are bootlegging the 300
uh apple headphones
they're bootlegging everything right now
like whatever you want these
[ __ ] if it's hot if it's a
device
it don't matter they got that [ __ ] it's
scary bro i mean it's not scary
it's a nice it's a nice bargain if you
really uh you know if you want to just
give your like six-year-old a pair of
300 headphones but you want to give your
six-year-old a pair of 300 headphones
pay 80 instead if he [ __ ] them up you
know they weren't real
that's that's that's cool right
that's cool look at that i'm just
you know i like i like i
i appreciate the real [ __ ] you feel me
like i don't want i don't want like a
fake virgin piece thinking and i'm
outside recording yeah to me like when
you start getting like fake designer you
look crazy
or even like like i've been wearing any
fake shoes for probably 15 years
but like back in the day
i would know if i had the what the dunks
that i would sell they were fake right
but that's like at the time they were
like three three thousand dollar pairs
of shoes like i can't wear these people
will know i can't afford these [ __ ]
oh yeah that's one of my favorite pairs
and what the dunks are tiffany dunks oh
i used to move them boys them tiffany
dunks crazy i had three ebay accounts
banned
damn oh man paypal [ __ ] hates me bro
at the time i'm 18 i don't give a [ __ ]
i'm like what the [ __ ] is paypal [ __ ]
you i just set up another one of my
mom's name and you see the [ __ ] they
trying to put on stockx name
yeah i think that's [ __ ] i think
nike's just mad that they're not getting
a piece of that pie
i don't know stockx is also full of [ __ ]
though cause i've
i've uh i've sold shoes on stockx
that they sent back because the box
wasn't in like pristine condition but
the box was fine
oh damn yeah they'd be tweaking on that
[ __ ] you get stuff on stockx yeah i got
a lot of [ __ ] i'm stuck
no it's convenient and then you can go
into some of these [ __ ] sneaker
stores in la and they're [ __ ] 150
over the stockx price and you'll be like
hey guys i could yeah i could just get
this [ __ ] out what are y'all [ __ ]
doing it is taxing
yeah some of these [ __ ] shoe stores
in la god bless them get your money but
they're full of [ __ ]
they're [ __ ]
the only place that i really went to
that was like fair was
hidden souls in um
fox hills mall shout out to the homie
he's he's got a dope story and they're
not i got a shout out cool kick show me
a lot of love bro well you're you're you
are who you are cool kids band you know
what i'm saying
those guys make so much money just
having a youtube channel that like why
are you why are you [ __ ] everyone
over on the sneakers
your youtube revenues [ __ ] it's got to
be crazy
that nigga's having any weight man
straight to stockx for me bud if i need
a pair of shoes like i just bought these
i just bought these jordan threes um
because i thought the suns were gonna go
to the finals and i'm a stupid [ __ ]
because obviously that didn't happen but
there was a pair of jordan threes
that uh
only dropped in the uk
they're called the uh court purple
threes their sons colors three is my
favorite shoe ever
couldn't find them anywhere i got them
on stockx took a while but i got them
and uh my plan my plan was to wear them
for the finals
we didn't go to the finals so
i don't know they're still dead stock am
i they're in my closet but i tell you
what if we get kd
i'm throwing them [ __ ] on
and i'm going to tijuana if y'all get kd
that's gonna be a good team
like atlanta look like a good team right
now
they still got a few moves to make
they're gonna get rid of john collins i
said i look good though i don't want
yeah they got the auntie marie and trey
trey young i mean
come on cece a dog
capella
you see a dog man shout out my dog cc no
clint capela he's he's great but he's
like is he great for the money they're
paying him like they could probably just
sign a javale mcgee low-key and like get
the same production kind of right
would you rather pay clint capello
however much he's making or pay javille
mcgee like five million dollars if
you're a gm what would you do i'll tell
you what how about this
i'm gonna put you in a [ __ ] up
situation
russell westbrook is your guy he came
out in cryptwalk on stage with you in
l.a
that's a [ __ ] big deal
you just got hired as the lakers gm
you're the general manager of the lakers
you call all the shots the brooklyn nets
call you
and they say
we will give you kevin durant for
russell westbrook
straight up
what do you do
i'm not doing it
i'm not doing that
you're a good friend
i'm just not doing that i don't even
think i don't even think uh
i don't think k.d and bryan can't exist
on the same team what do you mean
i don't think that's i don't think
that's gonna work
i want everyone to know that if we all
could have friends as good as being over
a doe
then our life would be [ __ ]
stupendous i don't
you would say no
we need red light
okay
mark cuban calls
i'm gonna get you to say yes
mark cuban calls
good
here it comes
hey hey bino uh congratulations on the
new job
uh great that you know a young man from
la is now running the lakers
you know
i got an itch for russell westbrook and
we want to rebuild i'll give you a luca
straight up for russ
no picks
no other assets
luca doncic for russell westbrook your
friend who came and [ __ ] walked at your
show
what do you say keep it rest man and i
love luca
i love luca i'm keeping rest you're a
[ __ ] amazing liar
i'm keeping me here
i'm keeping it ready
i think it look look
cold i just want to look
like sp if if he had curry speed
he'd be a dog like he's what he's saying
is
if the warriors call and say we want
russ for curry
you're going to say yes
i'm
that i'm i'm like
like russ you want to stay here or do
you want to go oh okay someone asked him
like rosie you want to stay here they
first want to stay well russ is going to
be like well you're my friend and now
you're running the team i feel great
yeah so we good does he give you like an
unlimited supply of his shoes or
something what's going on here
how many pairs of russell westbrook's do
you own
like two two eight white nights
oops
how many jerseys do you got
i don't got a jersey i needed yours you
need to get this like the whole
you sign you know the autograph need to
frame it
better get it soon because he ain't
going to be on the lakers much longer
unless you get the job he is going to be
here but when he leaves don't be a
thought if you get the job he'll be here
forever
what you know about i gotta throw back
robert woods rams
oh [ __ ]
that's dope the high school bro
that's big woody man
well
bino rideau's new album is out uh by the
time this comes out it'll be out it's a
mixtape sorry for the wait too
go get it video's already shot
you got a lot of visuals already done
for this
yeah yeah we got some visuals done um a
lot of visualizers music videos
so i mean a lot of content man are you
doing any other like uh do you have like
any other [ __ ] going on you got some
weed dropping yeah you gotta
open in any restaurants what do you got
going on outside of the rap game man
it's other [ __ ] you know what i'm saying
it's all in it's all in the roll out you
know i'm saying this just really kicking
off the ear for me okay so this just the
tip of the iceberg
i'd like to point out that no one should
ever hire you as an nba gm ladies and
gentlemen that's all right
that's we're gonna end the interview
vito rideau the best friend a man can
ask for
the new album
mixtape playlist whatever the [ __ ] we're
calling these things these days
it's out go get it sorry for the weight
too appreciate you pulling up man every
time yes sir